rosemann dabei herzlich willkommen zum
heutigen video ich bin wieder zusammen
mit dem nützen ding ich bin zusammen mit
luca und ihr kennt wahrscheinlich das
szenario wir haben eine mütze mit
komischen aufgaben drinnen kennt das
szenario nicht und spielen schere stein
papier darum wer eine aufgabe ziehen
das haben wir jetzt schon mal gemacht
das video trug den titel die dümmsten
youtuber weil das sind wir
wir machen das ganze einfach nochmal
eigentlich ist das eine lustige und
simple idee
deshalb würde ich sagen lukas im kopf
ich wollte es nur richtig kannst du
schreibst dann spielen wir das alle erst
einmal steht auf dem papier schere stein
papier schere stein papier max anfang
mit der ersten challenge und ich ziehe
das allererste mal und zwar dieses
papier
ich hoffe du kriegst eine zelle von mir
die persönlich das komplette video das
lädt das könnte sogar sein rundes ist
eine es ist eine die max geschrieben hat
oder indirekt zum anfang war ich etwas
für etwas was seine größte beichte und
ich habe es nicht gemacht weil ich mache
jetzt erst dann brauche ich eine sekunde
zu überlegen
das erste was sind jetzt einfällt erste
jetzt einfällt ist dass ich irgendwie
bericht in der 45 dafür sagen teilweise
ins bett gemacht habe kassel war ich da
ich mache manchmal immer noch auf die
leute deswegen sind die leute die neben
mir auf jeden fall
das war so eine geile sache okay ich
würde sagen machen direkt weiter mit
schnitt müssen schnieken mal angekommen
kein ding für mich es geht wieder los
wie beim letzten mal wird jetzt sage
zwei sätze die man so auf youtube nie
sagen solche ich sehe da kommen wachstum
sollte wieder alles machen wie beim
letzten der 26 ich kann nur ein witz
also leute ich sag jetzt einfach die
sachen aber das heißt wirklich nicht
dass ich sie support die afd ist
eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht das ist
auf jeden fall ein satz den man nicht
sagen sollte auf youtube erwarte
schwulsein ist für mich normal
nochmal ich habe selbst gesagt weil ich
musste ich unterstütze der eine der
beiden aussagen ja das sind ja auch
nicht sätze die man gerade auf youtube
nicht sagen sollte sondern meinungen die
man allgemein nicht vertreten sollte
aber ich glaube er wird es wieder so
nicht denken wenn man es auf youtube
sagt mittmann gegen homophobie gestimmt
aber egal wie alt man ist einfach
geschlagen dann würde ich jetzt
okay leute meine erste challenge ich bin
ein bisschen durch das s steht darauf
ist der channel von max sage in die
cover schreiben sage ich nur einen tag
in deinem nächsten youtube video und
dann habe ich eine andere lage in einem
snaplogic die leute
ich bin für die spicy changes bekannt xd
ich hey das ist ok film die story passt
es nicht okay leute ihr lebt jetzt hier
beim eine story und es ist ab in der
story drin kann man nichts machen also
folgt investment laser luca guckt euch
an gar nichts mehr da so leute dann
spielen wir die nächste runde
wir sind nie was anderes genommen ja
jetzt entsteht mich ist es eine von mir
nein nein nein mache so viele wie jetzt
war schon damals hatte das video wieder
ziehen
sie haben gestern noch frustriert alles
hier noch wie heute
[Musik]
ja
[Applaus]
über diese zeit bad fallingbostel bin
abdulaziz 39 42 41 3 und überlegt dass
der berühmte können 30
vor allem gewusst es auch machen nachdem
wir wussten nur post leute trainiert
auch mir bewusst wir haben ja schon
wieder aufgebaut werden gestern
trainiert und jetzt erstmal schön
aufwachen mit 45.000 die geschützte ich
heute gemacht habe
ok wack schnickschnack ist nächstes ich
unbedingt eine schwere alter wir sind
ziemlich dick ist das heißt die akteure
so dass von mir selbst ist ein stück
klopapier okay ist ein stück klopapier
den das ding ist man überlegt sich die
challenges wahrheit hofft dass der
jeweils andere ist beim aufschreiben
auch erstmal im dritten mal aufgefallen
so jetzt können auch selber sich die
selber bekommen ist
wir haben hier ihren spaß
na ja auch noch paris eine wunderschöne
verspricht
genau genommen sind nach spiele möglich
mit bewusster eine delikatesse entwunden
reich locken ja wir sehen uns wieder
wenn max aufgegessen hat ein kleines
stück wahrheit esspapier fand ich gut
früher gratuliert schere stein papier
leute ich nehme als nächste challenge
dieses hier ich hoffe einfach mal nicht
dass es von mir ist es ist vom max
verfasste einen promi guelpa blutprobe
pablo eins unterstützen
natürlich spielte letzter zeit so alle
drei tage vielleicht weil es leute damit
haben wir nicht gerechnet
eindrücke auch nicht ich bin echt froh
dass ich nicht gezogen haben also lieber
club hier ist ein alter ich hätte lieber
meine toilette gegessen hast du auch
noch das was sie schreiben überlegt was
du willst doch der unterstützer von
miguel pablo du musst in der größte
supporter größte fan von seinem content
also ich schreibe jetzt einfach mal
miguel pablo hat schönen merge es ist
ein positiver trigger ja okay so kommt
dann wieder sowie kaum grafikdisplay
klicke auf twitter und ihr seht schon es
wohl eher rausgehauen meine damen und
herren ich habe natürlich online weil
ich jetzt endlich letzter zeit immer
noch einer gewissen zeit nach einer
gewissen zeit kannst du schon okay aber
es ist bisher ausgeglichen
etwas besser als von mir oder nicht
[Musik]
nennen
das ist dann 250 leute meine fünf
positive dinge über leon mascha und ab
roulette also nicht fünf oder jeden
sondern fünf also das einst bei der man
sagt ein problem
[Musik]
also positive sache über leon masche ist
dass er nur manchmal straffällig wird
und kriminelle
nur manchmal nur selten wieder stimmt so
wird nochmal in der staffel der letzten
video update ist persönlich sogar
unglücklicher kerl das in ordnung so so
seien youtube das ist was anderes für
mich positive sache über abriss objektiv
bisschen besser geworden seit seinem
ersten rap versuchen würde ich sonst
aber sagen sagen habe ich viele sachen
und die letzte sache ist eine sache die
man in einer gewissen weise unterstützen
kann ist dass sie hält ihr ding
durchziehen und am ball bleiben so das
heißt nicht das was sie machen gut ist
sondern nur dass sie halt weiter machen
und sich so von sich selbst überzeugt
sind okay das war die letzte sagt max
nicht die letzte challenge ich hatte
gehofft dass diese sache wirklich als
erstes kommt sondern letzten mal auch
schon so
deswegen mache das jetzt eigentlich gar
keinen sinn mehr das war das was ich
frage was das komplette video effekte
teilt darfst den rechtlichen video nie
mit mehr als einsatz antworten
beziehungsweise etwas sagen das ist doch
okay dann würde ich sagen war das jetzt
die letzte challenge max was sagst du
dazu
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen okay das
hoffe ich nicht mag was als sonst auch
so ich wünsche euch einen schönen tag
jetzt sagen wieder jetzt weil du wirst
doch jetzt darfst du dir jetzt hast du
das macht es gut lass ein leichter das
hat jetzt sind sogar leute die mir
strafe mit dem christen
das ist für die kerbs niemand kann es
auch für dich